За останні роки в Україні сталося чимало гучних ДТП зі смертельними наслідками.
Причому нерідко це відбувалося у місцях, де авто не мало би бути -
на тротуарах, зупинках транспорту та пішохідних переходах.
Найгучніші дорожні аварії останніх років - у добірці DW.
Остання резонансна дорожня аварія сталася ввечері 24 липня у Києві.
Водій позашляховика Hummer проїхав на червоний
і на смерть збив дівчинку на пішохідному переході.
Від отриманих травм дитина померла в кареті "швидкої".
За кермом авто, за даними ЗМІ, був колишній боксер Кирило Островський.
Він намагався втекти з місця події,
однак його затримали і повідомили про підозру.
Йому загрожує до восьми років в'язниці.
Одразу кілька смертельних ДТП за участю мікроавтобусів сталося 20 липня.
Зранку на Миколаївщині пасажирський мікроавтобус зіштовхнувся з вантажівкою,
що стояла на проїжджій частині.
П'ятеро людей загинули на місці, серед них і водій маршрутки, іще 12 - були травмовані.
За кілька годин схожа аварія сталася у Житомирській області.
Маршрутний мікроавтобус зіштовхнувся з вантажівкою, загинули 10 людей.
Власника маршрутки затримали.
Резонансна ДТП, яка сталася торік 18 жовтня у Харкові, шокувала всю країну.
Тоді на перехресті зіштовхнулися автівки Volkswagen Touareg та Lexus.
Внаслідок аварії на місці загинули п'ятеро людей, які на той момент перебували на тротуарі,
шоста постраждала згодом померла в лікарні.
За кермом Lexus була прийомна дочка харківського бізнесмена - студентка Олена Зайцева.
Її взяли під варту одразу після трагедії - за перевищення швидкості і проїзд на червоний.
Дівчина визнала свою провину.
Нині вона та іще один підозрюваний у цій справі перебувають у СІЗО, судовий розгляд триває.
З моменту резонансної аварії за участі автомобіля колишнього народного депутата
та почесного прездента ФК "Карпати" - Петра Димінського - минуло трохи менше року.
Торік 18 серпня його Mercedes врізався в Opel Наталії Тріли - жінка загинула на місці.
Винуватцем ДТП визнав себе охоронець Димінського - Андрій Борщ,
хоча родичі загиблої запевняли - за кермом у момент трагедії був сам бізнесмен.
Згодом провину охоронця заперечили і в МВС.
У відомстві оголосили бізнесмена у розшук - він залишив територію України одразу після аварії.
Січень 2016 року, Київ.
Позашляховик Mercedes виїхав на тротуар біля станції метро "Лівобережна",
в результаті чого загинула жінка.
За кермом авто був Станіслав Толстошеєв, який є сином бізнесмена з Донеччини Андрія Толстошеєва.
Як засвідчили висновки експертиз, під час аварії водій втратив контроль через напад епілепсії.
Хоча до того про таку його хворобу не було відомо.
Толстошеєва визнали неосудним.